it's that one next that one facing us
just before lunchtime they swept in the
target the registered home of salim
Adibi in Fallowfield South Manchester
they laid a small explosive device on
the front door and stepped back the man
filming from his bedroom window couldn't
quite take it in his Street his neighbor
the actual family that had been there
had never really come across them in bad
ways it was always but even when I said
a load never seems to speak back to you
it was just like kept themselves to
themselves and that was about it
the terror investigation that started
last night at the Manchester Arena
quickly moved to the suburbs in the
south of the city the first arrest was
here on a road next to a supermarket in
Chilton he is 23 years old witnesses saw
him smiling as he was being arrested
yeah funding keep him on and up what's
hot dawn possibly that was slimy he was
smiling yeah thank how it's all
connected still isn't clear this city is
coming to terms with the idea that the
man responsible was one of them I'm
picking his movements and motives
starts on this street it could lead them
anywhere the main suspect may be dead
but this is still the biggest
counterterrorism operation Greater
Manchester Police has ever faced where a
DB sourced the parts for his bomb who
might have helped him are all priorities
for the police I think it's less likely
that they've worked alone to carry out
this terrorist attack I think is more
likely that there's other people I know
we've had one person at least arrested
already and I think that there will
probably be more what I really hope is
that there's not more bombs and more
suicide vests out there ready to be used
there will be further arrests the police
delete images and dashcam footage from
the public but nothing they find will
undo the horror of Monday night Tom
Parmenter Sky News Manchester